hey wait enjoy okay well that's
convenient
whatever we're gonna make our way down
the this thing does not I'm a pro gay
RP and JP JP are jacksepticeye points
yeah those are Japanese points no
I can't just turn around excuse me sir
stop us for speeding are you doing
you're not a good driver stop
sure I'm from America I don't need to be
a good driver good it looks shiny like
crashed into something on our screens
happens just lag this making it happen
you need to ramp out over there over the
fence down there over there who's really
descriptive right there in front of you
put down on the rocks or something I
don't know I rap on that people can even
this [ __ ]
alright whatever
you told me to rip the rice tent along
right here we ramp there in there yeah
yeah suits me yeah that's nice I see
okay come on Big Mama lining up here we
go wait Oh bad Oh bad Oh bad Oh bad
where's you oh we could have just gone
through the main gates oh no they're
closed - you're gone no he's going crazy
in there yeah we shot we might have
killed someone we might have killed
somebody
mark wives might have yeah hello mr.
chopper
you be nice be nice you be nice my truck
is not very you seem to be struggling
I'm gonna go backwards I'm gonna ramp it
backwards screw you do not have enough
speed do I got this I got this where are
you guys I'm gonna lay down covering
fire no you're not you're gonna blow us
up no I'm not did you blow
in your care thank you oh my face is
bright pink you know just go yes I hit
the top of defense
the cops like think that we're silly
okay good as long as they underestimate
us underestimate you maybe they okay
driving the jet go l1r 1r you're like
left and right and then banking rolling
pitching is all in lipstick
that was amazing